hey bro hey hold on you're on the
podcast so be respectful all right no I
didn't ruin every right no I was
shooting my show and I couldn't
guarantee ten o'clock and I got here at
10:30 I don't believe I want you um
today why don't you go to the gym and
workout only your legs and do that for
about don't grow huh do you think it's
because you've never had any adversity
in your life she never had to really
worry about how to better root yourself
to the ground
I know it so they're not so I'm asking
seriously so your legs being that short
and skinny that's not a condition well
sometimes you don't get enough calcium
to one part of your body well being milk
on your legs is not how you get calcium
into your bones
who talked to you about nutrition who's
the guy no okay there's Greg an expert I
[Music]
gave you guys wings I got you up out of
the nest it was not comfortable at first
but I got you out that's right and now
you're flying right yeah and now you're
like no no and I'm like don't do that
you're like are you a dragon I mean yeah
you're like I'm just like and you're
like you know say wait that's my that's
the noise and I'm just like that's me
you got some he's kicking he's kicking
everything Game of Thrones
you guys I wish you could see this he's
thank you yes I know but people
listening he's reaching in the air the
noise you make is like good oh don't
watch merely jump your next special that
you never do should be called oh my I
have never been more insulted and I've
seen a lot of pictures of you sometimes
that on the internet when you're young
mmm when you didn't have a beard and
when you had short hair mm-hmm and it
was interesting because like that's the
guy with the lunch pail right
what well wait what well some people go
through a transition and what they do is
they go there's the guy you shove in the
corner okay
aim your lunch whatever it is right or
or let's just shove them around or or
you know what that's what they do right
yeah no and then then you get mad Namira
you I'm gonna change that's true and
then you go any of your dad's like let's
get him a stylist and then he goes grow
your hair long grows scruff and then
reinvent yourself because your name used
to be
Dennis now it's Chris is that true no
that's not true my new who's never
Dennis could have been back then right
all right no it was not it couldn't have
been my name is Chris and only Chris
wait a minute hey no no it's all good
dude let's go back to fun huh
let's go back you know you're talking to
me the way I talk to that door guy I'm
saying haha are you laughing in a good
way or what's line you see what happens
is mmm blood starts to boil
yeah blood starts to boil right starting
to see the bun I see it and I don't want
to make [ __ ] I don't want to make your
body look like your bank account which
is what hello
dance okay okay Brian full ode dance Cal
don't start these because I could do my
shows and people go full of dead yeah
maybe people have called me sweet tart
tart nasty do you know how not do it
your next looks don't take this the
wrong way what your neck looks oh no
your eyes boy your neck looks us
unfortified I know let's say you know
bro I'm [ __ ] box anything for your
legs ever and we know that I squat and
that's okay I squat I squat every
[ __ ] 3-4 days not just the bar do you
squat because your legs I can do 225
five times probably not true right I've
worked very hard will you have new knees
and we know that your new eyes well your
your new knees have never been used so I
can see how you would bear some way what
are you talking about I have a new knee
we've never done anything with your legs
dude besides sit and stand ups no no no
no no [ __ ] and impose I like going to
the gym I work out very hard I sweat
very hard and I [ __ ] and I burned
calories man I do an 80s workout you do
lat pull-downs and you don't do that
benchpress on the go
what are you doing hey hey hey hey
Brendan what are you doing a lot of
fighter and the kid do it and being
respectful don't do around here there's
a lot of shitty [ __ ] there's at candles
we don't use there's some letters on the
ground Ken like chin look at a cleaning
service signs on the ground this place
this bird down there yeah this place is
not remember last time let the hangover
it looks like like yeah I was in no you
weren't you weren't in it I was three
guys were you I do that because I have
flames right here that can so that's
what's up so I go we've had literally
never spoken about that terrible no it's
not terrible [ __ ] amazing hey but why
did you go did you wake up and you were
like okay
Coffee and I'm tired of that I'm gonna
get flames on my hand you've got a keen
I think it allows you there's nothing
about you nothing
that would that would signify flame are
you [ __ ] out of your mind dude what
about you know what you're not your dude
I'm on that's right that's why that's
why I had to get it no don't say I did
know I'm on fire don't do that okay but
that is like a terrible 80s of Ryan no
not and there's nothing about you that
sweetie there's nothing there you are
basically low-energy all that old [ __ ]
your human broccoli that's I'm not
kidding no it's mine to be that way but
you work for you you're pale I'm good
like you need a nap all the time nah bro
I'm killing it what are you doing on the
phone no no don't do that
yeah dude don't do that don't snap snap
this don't stop no way dude Terrell
terrible way to introduce you to them
so it doesn't catch fire because I don't
want [ __ ] fire to catch see this my
retardant you're putting water I'm gonna
get water on this side I'm gonna go
[ __ ] stop it no stop it's not to get
water on that sniper that's hot I am
[ __ ] no why did you get but why did
you say let me see that okay
it's so annoying Chris fire man on fire
like my last special dude you don't get
it it has layers do not on your [ __ ]
wrist
in layers sweet tartness as they drive
by I like it
well don't be [ __ ] sweet tart tart
do-nothing sweet tart tart and about me
at all I'm a [ __ ] hard older dude
yeah I've seen a lot of [ __ ] dude
I think it tight you know it's so
hilarious I was at [ __ ] Starbucks
getting my second coffee today
yeah and the guy goes like this I came
in today without laughing he goes he
does Chris what you are not a household
name so don't act like the [ __ ] guy
at Starbucks he was laughed and he
played it good he was like what and I go
like this I go like this I looked at him
and I go like this Chris yeah people
actually I have family members who go
what's that guy crystally delial I know
they do so your name is not because they
have a listening problem and not hearing
problem now what's that guy Chris D'Elia
like dude and then what some people go
they don't do that I just heard famous
they don't do that dude they go yes you
to know something and I mean this so
seriously and so sincerely I'm gonna say
thank you I took a nap a Rip Van Winkle
nap for five years I woke up with my
hair way too long my nails way too long
and my [ __ ] beard way hydrated and D
hide some in question behind okay on me
up after my Rip Van Winkle nap you've
been training
I mean training yeah I mean so can your
shirt in your shorts and your undies
every single [ __ ] bag right you still
beam them up B you don't
asked one round bro you understand me
I'm talking I had him cut my nails and I
can't make a fist I be he did the
jujitsu for pleasure no no Chris did I
know he did for six years and I want to
say this [ __ ] you
what [ __ ] your [ __ ] oh wow jujitsu
okay if you know step to me when you're
ready soon as that that's not mine dude
I turn my [ __ ] off yours brother
dude don't mind I don't like how you say
bro after that and that's your phone you
know why because you're [ __ ] terrible
with your phone no cuz cuz I keep things
quiet right well although he's Jenkins
text me you know wear those sunglasses
the whole time you know what I don't
even realize when they're on or off
anymore what does that mean cuz you know
why because my my life is that cool okay
so when I have sunglasses on indoors I
don't realize that okay so I want to ask
you something
yo don't do that go ahead shoot ponder
you you are welcome to welcome two
fighter in the kid yes I know Chris
D'Elia is guesting yeah well is it yeah
well looks like this sumo first of all
your shoes make you
those are lifts obviously they're not
only outside of dude I'm six-two well
they're not their air maxes dude you're
acting like they're [ __ ] well in
there gold right there gold yeah well
they're matte they're like you know the
animatics ox don't go I don't care cuz
I'm not in the fashion that's obvious
slam you start out with a [ __ ] Grand
Slam not a slam man we got a bunch of
[ __ ] specials here at Denny's but you
just wanted the good old fashioned Grand
Slam that's not John that wasn't a slam
and your mouth is twisted in such a
disrespectful manner no the first thing
I want to say is okay what pick a shade
man pick a shade with that like a shitty
Crayola node why are you dressed like
Chris Gaines tend you know when Garth
Brooks wears the time for color church
it'll be green here on one side and then
black on one side yeah you do anything
I don't mean to open up the [ __ ] I
don't mean to open up the show with a
huge move like that but no you put on
there I knock ins what we're just hit
that because it's he look like an actor
from American Pie oh dude holder's dude
it looks getting you got that for free
that's such as that's such a [ __ ] I
did get it for free look man
dude that's such a hoodie you'd wear God
or free would not buy that you never got
that [ __ ] shades off right now senses
know why I gotta wear these dude mmm
futures to brown live on pancakes bro
what do you bro you you can finish your
pancakes last night no I only have got
that pancakes yeah I had a one butter
we're okay swingers they got nice
buttermilk pancakes shut up who says
buttermilk pancakes you say pancakes
yeah well no pain yes unless they're
like banana nut pancakes because his
border Lulu berry but standard yeah
pancakes they oh my god I like when they
say when they say buttermilk it turns me
it gets me going like now you go to
swingers every night right a lot yeah
and you you find a corner and you eat I
don't need people to be lining up but I
don't care I'm kidding
no but you did shut down Starbucks my
nephew called me and said hey Chris
D'Elia just walked in to mossy itza and
he's alone and I went yeah of course
he's alone cuz he's a weird went in by
you ate dinner by yourself and they go
yeah bro look at me you serial killer or
or you loser
no since one of the sushi bro did you
have some soup and rice
what do you don't eat raw fish yeah yes
you do do you do what are you saying man
did you order a mustard turkey sandwich
that's what you eat you ate sushi why
were you there by yourself dude I
[ __ ] you know what I do what
not only do I do I not invite anyone I
send a text out and I say I'm getting
sushi no one's invited and then I go by
myself you know why dude because I
[ __ ] up here bro hey I got his
[ __ ] blast can you do that have a
blast
I have a blast dude I just think
anything I want nobody's there to
[ __ ] be like ah but also [ __ ] them
dude I just chill you're right hangout I
have a good time and I eat sushi and I
go like this and I think about stuff
what do you talk about lash to do what
do you think about like seriously um I
think about like the people around me
and if someone falls and that would be
funny or like I'll think about something
I could talk about on stage or I think
that your mix you're probably mixed
somewhere you are you from the future
dude what the [ __ ] are you from the
future by 2018 [ __ ] dude right ha cheers
you guys you guys want me to tell you
what happens yes okay what happens to me
and Brian in the future troll hole no
say that I'm [ __ ] or I'm bust and
with creativity right now what they do
put the douche out there Brian can you
please do 30 minutes that's too long for
the comments don't we don't care we
don't care well no he sees the future
Rogen was like hey the crowds kind of
tough you know I was like I went mm-hmm
you did that
yeah did you say they were tough for
everybody and I was like that's really
obnoxious to me let me close this bad
boy out and actually did have a really
great set last night you really really
did yeah and it bugged me why I want you
to fail I'm just gonna come out and say
it I don't care don't you you like when
Brian I like when I like when my friends
fail hey Bros me room to ride today I'm
gonna do a video I want them to not go
no why I'd rather them stay home and
watch my Netflix special no one of them
what did he so if my if my if it's empty
there are six people
what is your face gonna be like
Oh
for my hey Chris you call me up yeah hey
man hey how'd it go
what happened with the show only it's so
annoying I'm so funny got like 16 people
were in the audience you're all right no
yeah that's so well yeah and you know
you'll be able to tomorrow's not selling
well either what are you doing nothing
what are you breathing uh I was I'm cold
it's cold outside so I mean I hope
Saturday's big I hope so
yeah me too oh so Tommy it's not going
to be when you see my back ripple and I
pull myself up like a champ
like a chimp through 30 times span while
talking to you why wouldn't I give that
to you as it's a gif it's a gift it's a
gift